[موسيقى]
بيساعدنا
كل يوم
اول حاجه
الحاجات اللي احنا بنستعملها كل يوم زيك
اليوتيوب او النتفليكس
عشان يعرفها
بيساعدونا كل يوم عشان
يجاوبوا اسئلتنا او
نعمل
عشان
يسهل لهم شغلهم
زي السوفت وير اسمه ايفا ايفا
بيساعدهم اللي هم يعملوا
اقل من كم ثانيه
كمان نقدر نستعمل في مذاكرتنا
يقدر يساعدنا اللي احنا نذاكر اسرع
وبطريقه اللي احنا نجيب بتاعنا بالمذاكره
فكده نجيب درجات اعلى وساعدنا
كمان حاجه نقدر نستعملها في بيساعدنا فيها
غير المذاكره او هو هو
يقدر يساعدنا اللي احنا
بنعمل
فاحنا لازم نستعمل
يساعدنا في الحياه
خليها اسهل ما استعملوش على حاجه
فاحنا
محتاجينز نتورك
مجال بيتطور كل يوم احنا لازم
[موسيقى]
نفهمه
ونستخدمه عشان نفيد البشريه ولو حد عايز
يطور من نفسه انت فيوتشر
شكرا
[تصفيق]